- Well, John Cena is in fast nine and,
(audience applauds)
I know I'm excited.
So, how did he end up in the movie?
- (sighs) Okay, so
obviously I'm multicultural,
you could have cast anybody
to be my brother, anybody.
- (laughs) Amazing, that's amazing.
I didn't even think of that, but yes.
- You could have cast anybody
in the world to be my brother
and it would be okay.
For two months before I went to filming
I created a shrine where I could
do all the combat training,
all the stunts and I had the charger there
to simulate the garage.
- Yeah.
- To get into this
downstate of mind.
The idea of the brother
worked great on paper
but when the time came
to cast it, anxiety.
Who could you cast to be Dom's brother
and 20 years into the game
and the audience knows
our mythology so much.
Who could you cast?
- Yeah, people are so invested, yeah.
- To play the brother.
- Yeah.
- And he comes into the shrine one morning
and I had this strange feeling,
and if you look back on my
Instagram you'll see the post,
'cause I thanked Pablo
as I had this strange feeling
that Paul Walker had sent him.
- Oh, you just had a feeling from, from?
Oh, that's magical.
- Very magical.